احنا من خلال ملاحظاتنا الميدانيه للاهالي
وللناس وللمرضى اللي بييجوا عننا المستشفى
وصف هذا الحادثه او الوضع اللي بمر فيه
الناس هي يعني كلمه كارثي قليل على اللي
بصير في الشعب الفلسطيني اصبحوا الناس بلا
ماوى بلا شراب بلا طعام بلا مامن وهذا كله
ظهر بشكل نفسي على على على الناس ظهر على
الاطفال ظهر على الكبار ظهر على الصغار لم
تعد هناك اي فئه من فئات المجتمع
الفلسطيني الا يعاني من الامراض النفسيه
والامراض النفسيه لها اوجه كثيره ومتعدده
رت على هذا الاطفال الاطفال الان بعانوا
من نوبات الهلع سموها المخاوف مجرد سماع
الطائرات او سماع القصف او سماع الاسعاف
داخل المستشفى بظهر عليه اعراض نفسيه انا
طبعا خيمه واحده استطعنا ان نشوف جميع
اعراض الصدمه شفنا ناس خايفين شفنا اطفال
عندهم سلوكيات هي مص الاصبع موجوده شفنا
اطفال عندهم سلس البول شفنا اطفال قلقين
جدا على على الابوين وعلى صحه
الابوين